[Musique]
depuis des années je me bats contre le
déclassement des hôpitaux de proximité
depuis des années nous nous battons
contre la sur administration de nos
services de santé animé d'une seule
logique comptable
depuis des années nous nous battons pour
que le travail des soignants soit
revalorisé allez vous redonnez humanité
cohérence lisibilité aux mesures qui ont
été prises
allez vous créer ce choc de confiance et
ce choc d'espérance tant attendu par nos
soignants et par nos concitoyens
il y va des valeurs de la république il
y va de la grandeur et de l'honneur de
la france et pour tous ceux qui se
battent aujourd'hui contre le virus
je n'ai qu'un message à leurs données il
va cros virus et vive la vie monsieur le
premier ministre savez vous qui a dit
récemment on n'y comprend plus rien ce
n'est pas bien gérée et ce n'est pas
bien expliqué et bien c'est le président
de la république lui-même
effectivement les français ont bien du
mal à vous suivre quand vous naviguez à
vue sans ligne directrice et sans
méthode
pire encore votre communication et votre
gestion ont tendance à opposer les
français
nous n'imaginions pas être frappé encore
si durement nous aurons besoin d'un état
fort temps nous accompagner dans cette
reconstruction
le chemin sera très long les 110
millions d'euros annoncés nous soulage
mais ne peuvent être qu'une première
étape vers un engagement encore plus
massifs l'eau l'assainissement les
routes les ponts les réseaux les
services publics les maisons tout est à
reconstruire
nous ne pouvons plus nous contenter de
déclarations dommage de soutien et
d'autres formes de compassion nous nous
devons collectivement d'apporter des
réponses à ces situations intolérables
et de plus en plus fréquentes
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
en fonction depuis cent jours et en
matière de sécurité
on attend toujours des actes forts vous
ne pouvez plus seulement commenté cette
escalade de la violence mais pointé le
problème et proposer des solutions
quand la république est attaquée la
république doit triompher la france
subit une vague sans précédent de
violences brutale et barbare
il faut réarmer dans tous les sens du
terme
forces de l'ordre nous en avons assez
des hommages verbaux tandis que la
suspicion pèse en permanence sur les
forces de l'ordre
nous en avons assez de la paix unité qui
deviennent irak pour les voyous nous en
a un peu assez du relativisme général
qui interdirait d'appeler un délinquant
un délinquant la peur doit changer de
camp
pas un mois ne passe sans que je sois
contacté par des élus désespéré par les
installations illicites sur leur commune
est incapable de lutter contre ces
dernières qui s'accompagne la plupart du
temps de nombreuses incivilités
la situation n'est plus soutenable pour
les élus mais aussi posé agriculteurs
les chefs d'entreprises qui font eux
aussi face à ces installations illicites
monsieur le premier ministre vous êtes
en poste à matignon depuis depuis cent
jours et la réalité c'est que vous
augmentez déjà les taxes des français je
veux parler du durcissement sans
précédent du malus écologique sur
l'automobile prévus dans le budget pour
en effet l'achat d'un véhicule neuf sera
considérablement alourdie par ce malus
dès le 1er janvier
cette politique budgétaire est non
seulement injuste et touchera
directement au portefeuille des ménages
mais elle a également suicidaire pour
les fleurons industriels français de
l'automobile que nous dit le terrain il
nous dit que les associations sont
aujourd'hui grandement fragilisée il
nous dit que la crise a eu des impacts
sur le fonctionnement général des
associations qui n'ont plus d'activité
génératrice de ressources comme les
lotos ou kermesse il nous dit enfin que
les impacts financiers de la crise amène
des questions inquiétantes celle du
dépôt de bilan voire de la possibilité
même de maintenir des effectifs salariés
quand elles en ont et pourtant pourtant
le plan de relance ne fait qu'effleurer
le sujet les clivages entre les
communautés de et les provinces
d'ailleurs de nouvelle calédonie se
cristallise et pendant ce temps là
aucune perspective n'est ouverte
il me semble que le gouvernement confond
trop facilement impartialité et
indifférence à l'avenir de la nouvelle
calédonie il ne s'engage pas ne joue pas
son rôle d'arbitré ne contribue pas avec
les partis calédonienne à définir des
perspectives allant au delà de ces
référendums à répétition de nombreuses
entreprises luttent pour leur survie
les associations comme les collectivités
territoriales se concentre sur les
actions de solidarité
en faveur des plus démunis je vous
demande monsieur le ministre
l'annulation de l'obligation de ce stage
incombant aux collégiens de 3e le
liraient ce sont deux acteurs importants
en concurrence frontale
quoi de plus stimulant ce secteur est
connu pour présenter déjà des niveaux de
concentrations élevées
est ce raisonnable d'aller plus loin est
ce raisonnable de faire intervenir un
fonds de pension sur un marché où la
vision stratégique à long terme est
essentielle la france ne peut pas
abandonner son allié sa soeur l'arménie
être spectatrice d'un génocide
les abandonner ses nous renier les
ignorer ces nous trahir
l'indignation est nécessaire mais ne
sauve pas des vies il faut agir
[Musique]